yacine tu penses vraiment présenter à la
présidence d'eric naulleau il va qu'il a
eu ces mots j'ai mon eric zemmour
eric naulleau lire à paris les on le
sait qu'eric n'ira pas alors si si si
eric zemmour il bâtit va bah oui enfin
moi je veux dire à partir du moment où
quelqu'un comme eric zemmour a
désacralisé une campagne qui est quand
même un moment important de notre pays
je vois pas pourquoi un bouffon comme
moi nu au sens noble ne rejoindrait pas
cette mascarade parce qu'aujourd'hui il
suffit de pardon mais je trouve quelque
chose d'assez comment dire assez
palpable il suffit de dire on n'aime pas
les musulmans on est à 8% et on est
suivi derrière par une machine
médiatique moi pour l'instant je ne
connais toujours dit j'aime pas la
danette je suis affûté au japon est
aujourd'hui plus clairement moi j'allume
ma télé depuis deux mois ça fait
soixante jours que j'allume la télé tous
les jours il ya quand même un rythme
d'islamophobie de propos hyper dangereux
et je me suis dit moi aussi je fais
rentrer moi aussi j'ai envie peut-être
d'appeler les gens au vote d'ailleurs je
prendrai des électeurs à personne
puisque visiblement les gens que je vise
nice ne s'intéressent même plus à la
politique donc bien sûr que j'ai envie
d'y aller c'est lui et vivent à givet
points alors c'est ça c'est que si tu y
vas iveco ouais comme la piscine quoi
allait plus je plonge voilà je veux dire
un moment il faut remettre les choses à
plat je vous entendez dire gagner c'est
hyper inquiétant quand même se tourner
vers moi être se dire que
potentiellement je peux gagner mais je
reviens on y va c'est pour gagner non on
n'y va pas pour gagner frère on y va
parce que franchement objectivement est
la risée du monde je connais la plupart
des chroniqueurs autour de cette table
les amis on parle de nous dans le monde
entier avec un gars qui a flingué notre
système politique c'est à dire que ça
c'est pas marrant c'est l'agent smith et
on a eu très n'y a eu en train de poser
il frappe à la limite je te dirai
quelque chose c'est un homme d'affaires
il a eu des succès il a eu des échecs on
est aujourd'hui et mon nom est mort ce
n'est pas un homme d'affaires très
sévère on est libre et non mais les
rares valeurs pour se préparer à l'ailé
compris dans un bon soir 3 antoine
emmène en soit c'est vrai que c'est pas
c'est vrai que c'est pas énorme non
cerexhe pas d'hommes d'affaires exerçant
un éditorialiste panneaux ces panneaux
bien sûr c'est le présenter à l'élection
présidentielle c'est d'avoir des
signatures début ça c'est la loi c'est
la règle on rentre pas là dedans c'est
pour l'expliquer critère c'est pas parce
que lui il estime que les thèmes qui
sont évoqués ne lui plaisent pas que ça
doit faire un critère pour être ou pas
candidat vous avez une com des dates de
candidatures séparatistes c'est à dire
que vous visez une partie de l'électorat
qui soi-disant n'irait pas voter on a
bien compris hier dans vos propos que
vous visez un électorat qui sort est
musulman et trois du tennis en reste et
j'ai pas dit ça parce que paddy son nom
ronflant je sais engagement je n'ai pas
dit ça faisait pas je n'ai pas dit ça
plaît non parce que si vous mentez
valider si vous mentez c'est ce que j'ai
dit
il et tous les quotidiens
vous avez des intrus qui répond après
vous répondrais ce que j'ai dit tu sur
ce plateau et après je vous laisse
continuer soit vous dites la vérité soit
vous montez et disent pas ce que j'ai
dit non pas dans faut pas parler comme
ça ce que j'ai dit aux gens hier les
musulmans voté pour moi non mais vous
expliquer que ce sont ceux qui se
sentent persécutés par la candidature
d'eric zemmour dont les musulmans parce
qu'on n'est pas imbécile on comprend
bien je voulais visez-vous d'envoi
l'ancien mentor de prénationale vous
savez quand on est pris dans la
république on essaie de viser tous les
français et parler à tous les français
mais vous votre marque de fabrique votre
came c'est d'essayer d'expliquer que la
france est raciste que la république est
raciste et qu'on en a contre les
musulmans et donc vous voulez utiliser
sa com faisait le ccf en fait vous êtes
le plan mais la vague non mais vous
affilier à tout et n'importe quoi c'est
un métier c'est votre vérité est quelque
chose que j'ai autre vérité ici mais
c'est votre vérité n'est pas d'embêter
même si on n'est pas dans le btp reste
on reste voilà on essaie bien de dire la
vérité
et la vérité lorsque vous adore mais là
on comprend pas soyons on parle de la
candidature de yassine belattar puis
pensez vous qu'ils puissent être
candidat anti zemmour la question aller
simple fait des réponses simples valérie
benaïm noria somptueux dîner tu dis
c'est pas marrant ce qui se passe je
suis d'accord avec toi c'est pas marrant
ce qui se passe mais tu dit également
que tu veux te présenter comme si comme
tu y vas à la piscine
or moi or pour ce que tu me diras comme
si comme si tu allais à la piscine or
justement tu participes à ce grand
cirque à décrédibiliser la politique
puisque en y allant en disant j'y vais
comme je vais à la piscine tu joues tu
joues le clown tu fait le clown et et
bah c'est pas c'est pas dire que la
politique c'est noble c'est pas avoir du
respect pour les pour les gens qui vont
aller voter qu'ils vont mettre un ticket
dans l'urne et y compris en disant je le
candidat des quartiers ce que tu as dit
hier soir le quartier le candidat des
quartiers à candidat c'est un candidat
des français et
bien allez vite voir il faut qu'on se
parle suffisamment j'ai beaucoup
d'estimé et d'ailleurs on a appris à se
connaître tous autour de cette table
dans les coulisses de cette émission il
faut comprendre dans quelle violence on
est moi je suis un privilégié je dis la
vérité comme la plupart d'entre nous je
fais un métier que j'aime pas genton en
page 11
je suis très bien payé je fais des
spectacles qui sont complets
moi ça va je pourrais faire comme tous
mes collègues artistique qui émane de
nos quartiers et dire c'est derrière moi
moi je suis arrivé c'est plus mon
problème moi je vois une souffrance et
tous on est des professionnels des
médias mois les médias ça me fait
souffrir c'est à dire que quand je vois
la télé la magie est l'un des agents qui
prennent la parole comme la série vient
d'être fait c'est à dire un tu te dis tu
te mange une comparaison hier six fois
dans une émission on te traite dit cela
me met toi de ton côté tu mets un euro
dans la machine mais je veux dans la
magie arrière tu vas tout ça tu m'a dit
viens on me trouve dans le couloir ou
bien tu es un fashionista du parti serbe
et rich non mais c'est pas le problème
je te dis moi ma bande dessinée préférée
qui m'a rendu misanthrope ça s'appelle
watchmen tout ceci est une blague nous
sommes dans une blague et la folie de
léry je te le dis moi j'ai la technique
chez nous c'est la cité non mais c'est
pas là cités mais je ne leur dis valérie
si j'ai 500 signatures je suis hyper
inquiète c'est à dire vraiment faut
remettre l'église au centre du village
moi ce que je veux c'est qu'aujourd'hui
j'ai comme eric ont joué avec les mêmes
armes qu'eric zemmour il vient sur tous
les plateaux dit je suis pas candidat il
fait un débat face à un homme politique
comme mélenchon mais je suis pas
candidat alors expliquez moi en quoi la
parole d'eric zemmour vaut plus que
celle d'un citoyen tout aussi brillant
tout aussi cultivé parce que le problème
c'est qu'il est talentueux dans ce qu'il
fait matthieu delormeau est ce qu'il ya
un mois que j'ai mouillé franchement et
ir ça ça m'a fait ça m'a fait ça m'a
fait peur ce que j'ai vu un signe quand
je suis fière parce que tu es un homme
dangereux tuer eric zemmour à l'envers
c'est à dire que par définition pour toi
si on n'est pas trop musulman on est
forcément anti musulman si on ne prend
pas position pour les musulmans c'est
que forcément on est contre c'est très
dangereuse que tu fais tu montres les
gens contre les hordes yacine moi je le
vois tous pratiquement tous les jours
parce qu'il fait sa chronique et on a
déjà eu cette discussion tous les deux -
sin sur voilà yacine c'est vrai je vous
dis je le redis je pense que si moi je
pensais qu'il ya si il était antisémite
comme si eric naulleau je pensais que
c'était un facho je pense que je
travaillerai pas avec eux voilà c'est
tout donc non mais juste le géant des
mers soit juste pour aller au bout tu
sais aujourd'hui il ya un très beau
papier dans le monde qui est sorti de
louise couvelaire qui disaient ouais ou
et la parole des gens issus des
quartiers de surcroît ou et la parole
des arabes et des noirs parce que quand
on dans le débat public derrière c'est
un rouleau compresseur
je vais vous dire quelque chose depuis
hier soir moi j'ai été écarté twitter
parce que twitter est une vraie
plateforme qui plébiscitent la parole
raciste raciste homophobe un antisémite
c'est l'anarchie twitter non mais ayant
fait parvenir je vais d'ailleurs mais
c'est vrai que tu as été un peu dur sur
eric avec fachos l'amérique et je
reviendrai sur ce qu'il savait ce nom
mais un moment les amis quand moi je
monte sur un plateau déjà je monte seul
j'ai pas l'impression qu'on soit quinze
artistes pour répondre qu' un moment se
disent mais attends moi je fais pas
traversé mon époque en me disant mon
projet c'est de jouer dans validé saison
3 et quand on parle de thématiques qui
me touche dont je suis issue je suis
hyper fier de venir de banlieue je suis
hyper fier d'être musulman je suis hyper
fier d'avoir des origines marocaines
mais ça m'empêche pas de respecter cette
république quand je me réveille ça ne
m'empêche pas de me dire que ce qui se
passe dans mon pays pardon de vous dire
ça je suis dans 82 ans j'ai vécu toute
cette espèce de chape de plomb de la
gauche qui nous a totalement anéanti les
gens de quartier voyer jean n'est plus
moi derrière la gauche que derrière
l'extrême droite pourquoi parce qu'en
fait il y avait le syndrome de
l'imposteur pour les gens quartier dès
qu'on réussit fallait se tourner vers
touche pas à mon pote et on a été
abreuvé d'association loi 1901 en se
disant on va leur donner de losail dans
la sauce il y demande
non mais ça permet aussi peut-être à
lies in de lever une ambiguïté parce que
oui c'est vraiment on n'arrête pas de
murmurer oh voilà exactement tu es un
islamiste août est un antisémite ou
temps ceci ou cela et voilà puisque il
ya une accusation et et que ça te
heurtes et voilà officiellement mais
18,3 ailleurs vraiment je déteste ce
truc de dire je les copains juifs des
copains musulmans je veux dire j'ai des
copains de vie oui - s'avère que là où
on est plutôt rigaux il ya des connards
partout donc je suis hyper ravis que ma
vie en france permettre de me dire j'ai
david g et stéphane g mamadou g rachid
et on vit ensemble et s'avère qu'on
évolue avec le temps mais si tu veux
valérie parce que je te remercie pour
cela nous on est parti sur un malentendu
comme ça sur un plateau où tu me disais
moi valérie bénaïm oui j'entends ça et
parce que j entendais pour double dit
ces mots justes si tu veux l'idée c'est
que moi ma meilleure rams et le
quotidien c'est à dire si dans une
journée de 24 heures tu me prends pas la
main dans le sac en train de dire elle
est juif c'est qu'à priori je le fais
pas et en plus tu sens les gens c'est à
dire que tu dis bon moi j'aime rentrer
sur un plateau est né ici je me sens
chez moi et mes copains artistes m'ont
laissé tomber et et moi je suis très
marginale non c'est vrai pas que
s'appelle en marge franchement ya
beaucoup de gens qui t'ont laissé tomber
non mais parce qu'en fait je leur ai dit
tu es tombé yacine c'est aussi parce
qu'il y avait cette suspicion donc il
fallait donc plein de gens qui t'ont
laissé tomber non non non non et même
mêmes qui disent et qu'ils me le disent
à moi qu'ils ont dit ah si le faire moi
qui emploient ce type là c'est un
antisémite cela s'est parfois aussi donc
à un moment il faut lever
l'ambiguïté valérie valérie à raison
peut-être il faut voilà comme ça au
moins ce sera fait terminé mais moi ce
que je veux pas vraiment valérie parce
que ce que j'aimerais c'est que de cette
émission ne finissent pas dans un
tribunal en se disant le sujet c'est ce
qu'il est antisémite la réponse
factuellement en me réveillant tous les
matins sénat donc fin de l'histoire mais
moi je peux pas passer ma carrière en
dise tiens j'ai un spectacle mais
n'oubliez pas je ne suis pas antisémite
jeumont papa de blanche je sais qui je
suis simplement suffisant les gens qui
m'aiment les gens avec qui je travaille
s'ils savent qui je suis c'est suffisant
ça fait comme ça ça fait longtemps il ya
une suspicion qui secret parce que
malheureusement les gens se connaissent
pas dont je suis au régime donc j'essaye
de maigrir mais je pourrais passer mes
journées à faire déjeuner dîner petit
déjeuner en faisant et tu le sais ya
beaucoup de gens dans de multiples
métiers qu'ils font l'attaché de presse
de m vous avez vu suis pas antisémite en
nom vient voir mon spectacle
si les antisémites eh bien peut-être que
j'ai vu lis moi je veux pas être éliminé
du débat parce qu'on veut on a des
suspicions sur moi on veut que je veux
qu'on m'élimine ou qu'on me contredisent
sur des choses valables moi je suis pas
en train de dire que zemmour n'est pas
légitime si zemmour est là aujourd'hui
c'est que ça fait 40 ans que les bolides
j quand vous êtes arrivé sur le plateau
moi j'aimais sur le fond mais vous
veniez à l'est jamais sur le fond parce
qu'en fait vous ne faites que du
spectacle vous faites comme vous étiez
quelqu'un qui fait rire les gens vous
amener des gens à vous et après
effectivement est ce qu a dit jordan
bardella et pourtant c'est loin d'être
mon ami je le combats depuis des années
leurs ascendants nationale c'est vrai ce
qu'il a dit en fait vous amener des gens
et vous emmener les gens à faire des
fatwas contre les gens qui s'opposent à
lomé je sais que j'ai vu contre vous
mais si vous savez c'est bien au
contraire c'est au players si mal et
tout le confort d'un mec camuzat galerie
tools est amis on va passer à ce qui
s'est passé avec